انظر ، لقد أراد الرئيس ترامب مغادرة
سوريا لبعض الوقت ، لقد حاول القيام
بذلك مرة واحدة من قبل بطريقة متسارعة مماثلة ،
ولهذا السبب
استقال وزير الدفاع السابق جيم ماتيس ، لذلك
لا تحتاج إلى أن يقدمه الجميع له أكثر من
القول مرحبًا هذه منطقتنا
هذه أرضنا نود
استعادتها والرئيس ترامب هذه
موسيقى لأذنيه لا أعتقد أنه
فهم بالضبط ما كان يوافق
عليه أو يعلنه ليلة الأحد
المشكلة هي أن الأكراد قد أحرقوا
مرة واحدة من قبل هكذا  إنهم ببساطة
لن يثقوا به مرة أخرى ، يعلم الجميع
أنه يريد أن يقوم مسؤولو الأمن القومي من
حوله بمحاولة إدارة
رحيل بطيء نوعًا ما
لإبطاء تحطم السيارة وجعلها أقل
تدميراً ، لكنه أظهر للجميع مرة أخرى
ذلك  إنه يريد الذهاب إلى
المخارج وهذا يعني أن
حلفاءنا الأكراد السابقين وغيرهم في
المنطقة سوف ينظرون إلى دول أخرى مثل روسيا
مثل الدكتاتور السوري الأسد على أنهم
مؤيدون لهم في العراق.  من أجل البقاء على قيد الحياة من هذا النوع ،
تعرف سياسة ترامب الخارجية الفوضوية
حيث لا أحد يعرف حقًا أين
يقفون كما تعلمون يومًا ما كان يحذر
تركيا من الدمار الاقتصادي يوم
الثلاثاء بنبرة مختلفة تمامًا على الأقل
مع التغريدات ، وهنا واحد منهم
الكثير من الناس بشكل ملائم  ننسى أن
تركيا هي شريك تجاري كبير
للولايات المتحدة في الواقع ، فهم يصنعون
الإطار الفولاذي الهيكلي لطائراتنا المقاتلة من طراز F-35
، ويتذكرون أيضًا والأهم من ذلك أن تركيا
عضو مهم يتمتع بمكانة جيدة في
حلف الناتو وأن أحدهم قادم في وقت سابق.  إلى الولايات المتحدة
هو ضيفي في 13 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) ، أعني أن هذا
مجرد تناقض معتاد لترامب أم أن
هناك شيئًا آخر هنا جيدًا أنت تعرف
نعم لقد قام ترامب بأعمال تجارية في تركيا
قبل أن يصبح رئيسًا ، نشرت إيفانكا
ترامب شيئًا عن
تهنئة أبراج ترامب
بافتتاح اسطنبول ولكن  حقيقة
الأمر أنه قطع وعدًا في حملته الانتخابية
بأنه يريد
حذفها من مغادرة سوريا وأنه لا
يريد تحسين العلاقات مع تركيا
والبلاد.  لذلك كل هذا يتناسب مع
نمط بحثه عن أبسط
طريقة للخروج ، وبعد ذلك يمكنك أن ترى ما
حدث بعد حصوله على
الإحاطة العسكرية مساء يوم الاثنين ، فقد عاد
من بعض خفة دمه بمجرد أن
أتيحت الفرصة للناس لشرح ذلك له
مرة واحدة أيضًا بدأ المشرعون الجمهوريون
في الكونجرس بالضرب عليه ،
وهذا ما انتبه إليه
وهذا عندما حاول تعديل
تحركاته السابقة من ليلة الأحد